[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sans public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat mais aussi
c'est une nouveauté depuis ce soir en
podcast sur Youtube 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société voici le
sommaire de ce 30 novembre la sécurité
des Jeux Olympiques en question après
les annonces du préfet de police de
Paris des périmètres élargis autour des
sites des épreuves un QR code
obligatoire pour les riverins des
interdits des dérogation en pagaille qui
laisse craindre une usine à gaz bref la
méthode n'a pas plu au parlementaires
résultat Laurent NZ était auditionné cet
après-midi au Sénat comment s'est-il
défendu peut-on organiser des jeux
olympiques sans renier lourdement sur
les liberté publique ce sera notre
premier débat dans une minute et puis
c'était il y a de semaines la Commission
européenne prolongait de 10 ans
l'utilisation du glyphosate pour les
agriculteurs au grand dâ des
associations qui se battent depuis des
années sur les effets pour condamner les
effets des pesticides sur notre santé on
a constaté dans dans les résultats
d'analyse qu'il y a une augmentation du
taux de glyphosate dans nos urines hein
nous simples citoyens lambda qu'on soit
en ville ou en campagne hein et qu'on
soit agriculteur ou qu'on soit en bureau
et bien on a des de glypholate important
et qui augmente au moment de la
saisonnalité de l'épendage des
pesticides comment le lobby du
glyphosate a-t-il obtenu gain de cause à
Bruxelles pourquoi la France s'est
abstenue alors que jusqu'en 2019
Emmanuel Macron était clairement opposé
à l'usage du pesticide les agriculteurs
n'ont-ils vraiment aucune alternative on
répond à toutes ces question dans 3ois
quart d'heure mais d'abord donc on
détaille le dispositif de sécurité
annoncé par le préfet nèz beaucoup de
policiers et beaucoup d'interdits Flor
sauvage des forces de l'ordre déployées
en masse des restrictions de circulation
autour des sites olympique et
paralympique des QR codes nécessaires
pour accéder à certains périmètres le
préfet de police de Paris Laurent nunèz
a dévoilé hier les grandes lignes du
dispositif de sécurité pour les Jeux
Olympiques qui auront lieu du 26 juillet
au 11 août prochain quatre périmètres de
sécurité différents seront misise en
place dans les zones rouges la
circulation d'engins motorisé sera
interdit sauf dérogation pour éviter
d'éventuelles attaques à la voiture
bélier la décision a été prise de mettre
en place ces périmètres non pas de 3
heur avant la compétition donc pas de 3
heures avant la parade vous l'imaginez
bien mais plusieurs jours avant au Sénat
la mise en place d'un QR code pour
accéder à certains périmètres suscite de
nombreuses interrogations comment cela
va concrètement s'organiser euh sur
quelle base légale quels seront les
contrôles quelles seront les pièces
justificatives bref quelles seront les
garanties pour les libertés individuelle
dans le cadre de la mise en place de ce
QR code pour circuler dans les zones
rouges les résidents disposant de
parking ou de plac de stationnement
devront s'inscrire sur une plateforme en
ligne pour obtenir un QR code qu'ils
devront présenter lors des contrôles
pour le QR code il faut un algorithme il
faut la collecte de données
subsidiairement du stockage et du
traitement de ces données donc de toute
façon ça suppose la manipulation de
données personnelles et puis vous avez
aussi l'obligation de de déclarer
l'identité des gens qui vont venir chez
vous
pour regarder de votre
balcon les épreuves ou en tous les cas
les manifestations donc ça suppose quand
même quelques garanties voilà afin
d'obtenir des garanties sur
l'utilisation de ces données le sénateur
loï kV a saisi la Commission Nationale
de l'Informatique et des Libertés et
déplore que les parlementaires n'ai pas
été consultés en amont sur ce projet de
QR code on nous a promis des Jeux
Olympiques populaires sont-ils libertid
voilà le thème de notre débat avec
Florence Bertou bonsoir bienvenue vous
vous êtes maire du 5e arrondissement de
Paris libre affilié au au Républicain
jean-baptisteon ah ben voilà j'adore
démarrer mon émission par une erreur sur
sur mes invités ça arrive vraiment très
très rarement horizon ben voilà je le
saai pour la prochaine fois
Jean-Baptiste Guégant j'espère que j'ai
bon spécialiste de la géopolitique du
sport co-auteur de ce livre l'Atlas
géopolitique du sport publié aux
éditions Autrement Anne Charlen Bezina
bonsoir et bienvenue constitutionnaliste
et maître de conférence en droit public
et Tam tranu bonsoir bonsoir Thomas pour
sens public je commence avec vous
Florence Bertou les impératifs de
sécurité et on est tous conscient autour
de cette table qui en a évidemment
beaucoup quand on organise un événement
tel que les Jeux Olympiques est-ce
qu'ils vont priver c'était mon titre les
les parisiens ou ou même les Français de
ces jeux populaires alors en tout cas on
a bien compris qu'autour des sites de
compétition on en a quoi à peu près 25
hein si j'ai bien compté vous alleit
avoir un système un peu compliqué j'ai
compris qu'on avait quatre périmètres de
protection alors on voit un un peu ce
que c'est pour les accrédités on voit à
peu près ce que c'est pour les personnes
qui ont qui sont munies de billets mais
alors après l'exercice se se complexifie
parce que vous avez les riverins vous
avez les invités des riverins vous avez
les voitures alors si j'ai bien compris
le transit non mais peut-être bien que
oui pour les voitures quand vous avez la
chance ou la malchance j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas d'avoir d'avoir un
parking donc oui la la en tout cas les
capacités de mobilité des parisiennes et
des Parisiens essentiellement ceux-là
quand même et puis ceux qui sont en
scène saint-enis vont être très très
encadré est-ce que c'est vraiment une
surprise qu' a annoncé hier je pense
qu'on nimaginait pas que ce serait euh à
ce point-là c'est à ce point-là au moins
pour deux raisons il y a l'ampleur
évidemment des Jos hein ces millions de
personnes que on attend et puis je vous
apprends rien il y a le complexe il y a
le contexte international c'est-à-dire
que évidemment h avec que passe
notamment au Proche Orient au
MoyenOrient et cetera et cetera en
Ukraine et bien évidemment les
clignotants les clignotants sont au
rouge donc ça va concerner les sites et
puis ça va concerern avant la
programmation au sens strict de toutes
les compétitions vous aurez cette
cérémonie d'ouverture et
cette la cérémonie d'ouverture
évidemment il y a encore beaucoup de
choses à à raconter il y il y a pas mal
de précédents Jean-Baptiste l'impératif
de sécurité il existe pour tous les jeux
alors on va peut-être pas comparer avec
Pékin ou Moscou parce que c'est pas tout
à fait le voilà la même opinion publique
ou le même impératif mais si on compare
avec les Jeux de Londres ou peut-être
aussi les les jeux de Rio est-ce qu'il y
avait des mesures aussi restrictives en
matière de liberté publique alors déjà
il faut aussi se souvenir qu'il y a eu
Munich 72 et qu'on a vu une délégation
être complètement littéralement
assassinée donc ça il faut l'avoir dans
un coin de la tête après effectivement à
Londre c'était plus ouvert mais il y a
eu un contrôle il y avait une très forte
présence policière on avait pas non plus
connu le covid avec justement les QR
codes et cetera on avait pas ce risque
là le retour de la guerre c'est une
réalité c'était pas le cas au Brésile
c'était pas le cas à Londres et on
aurait probablement eu une augmentation
de la sécurisation après on a la chance
d'être dans une démocratie et on peut en
parler c'est ça aussi l'intérêt on peut
en parler on peut et d'ailleurs il y en
a en a on aura des recours devant la
justice enfin tout notre démocratie
fonctionne donc on est au cœur de ces
enjeux de liberté publique liberté
individuelle un charina est-ce que le
gouvernement va trop loin c'est ça la
question en fait parce que qui a des
restrictions tout le monde était prêt à
l'accepter est-ce que là ça va un peu
trop loin il y a déjà une première chose
c'est la sensibilité de l'opinion
publique à ces questions de liberté
fondamentale depuis justement la crise
sanitaire c'est-à-dire qu'on a un peu eu
le sentiment notamment avec la
multiplication des états d'urgence si on
prend depuis 2015 les états d'urgence
terroriste on est resté près de 6 à 7
ans dans dans des dans des systèmes
exceptionnels on est encore dans un
système d'exception à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme donc il
y a quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de
l'angoisse un peu de de cette fuite en
avant dans un régime sécuritaire sorte
d'état d'urgence permanent quoi c'est
pas tout à fait ça mais on pas loin
voilà les juristes appellent ça
l'accoutumance à ces régimes d'état
d'urgence pourquoi parce que c'est très
simple c'est-à-dire que on est dans une
république exécutive dans ce cas-là ce
sont les autorités qui décident et il y
a pas besoin d'en arriver au délibératif
au Parlement et cetera donc il y a cette
angoisse est-ce que l'exécutif va trop
loin alors l'ampleur des JO évidemment
elle elle est importante l'impératif de
sécurisation on on l'a tous compris il
fait partie des impératifs
constitionnels mais c'est vrai que
l'usage du QR code tout ce qui va être
périféri liberté ça peut être toujours
un petit peu borderline à mon avis
notamment parce qu'en fait il y a un
impératif que les juges donnent et qui
est vraiment important aussi pour la
démocratie celui de proportionnalité
vous ne pouvez pas prendre des mesures
plus simples et plus rapides si elles
sont plus attentatoires aux liberté donc
il va falloir toujours être dans le
moins 10 ans en matière de liberté et
j'ai peur que là on soit peut-être dans
un petit cran au-dessus pour certaines
de ces mesures notamment sur les invités
où vous n'avez pas de motif d'intérêt
public à à à justifier des restrictions
aussi importantes euh avec avec des
contrôles d'identité des données
personnelles qui sont stockées et c'est
pour ça que le Parlement est
complètement dans son rôle aujourd'hui
dans l'idée de voilà de parler des
libertés fondamentales et de les évoquer
c'est vrai que si on habite dans dans
une zone rouge c'estàd un des sites et
qu'on veut soit inviter des amis soit
éventuellement louer son appartement il
y a pas mal de de Franciliens qui se
posent la question ça risque d'être
sérieusement compliqué quand même oui ça
va être compliqué mais je je voudrais
revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur
Londres parce que je suis allé au au
Jeux de Londres c'est moi aussi j'y suis
allé une journée j'avis pas souvenir
d'une d'un d'unage pard c'était très
léger enfin il y avait on était
évidemment on était si j'ose dire
encadré mais c'était quand même très
très léger alors c'est lié aussi au
dimensionnement des sites hein c'estd
que quand vous avez des sites éclatés
vous vous multipliez évidemment les les
dispositifes puis là on a choisi d'avoir
des sites pardon vous interrompre mais
aussi et ça ça va être le panage de ces
jeux en pleine ville quoi le le Grand
Palais c'est c'est c'est quand même
assez génial de pouvoir organiser plus
je crois que c'est les épreuves de de
des scam par exemple bon ah là on est au
cœur de Paris forcément euh c'est plus
difficile peutêre dans un St c'est et
puis on a voulu mettre mettre en avant
la scène bon en tout cas on est allé
très loin euh peut-être certains diront
un peu loin c'est-à-dire que il y a un
prix à payer si on veut avoir une très
très belle cérémonie c'est peut-être
formidable pour sans doute les les
images en mondiovion mais ça va être
très compliqué pour nous mais Londres on
avait moins ça et et les questions qui
se pose sur les libertés je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous c'est aussi
parce qu'on a en démocratie qu'on se les
pose mais souvenez-vous de la loi euh
euh de la loi Colomb hein que n'a-t-on
reproché à Colom ministre de l'intérieur
quand il a voulu faire passer des
mesures d'exception en raison du
contexte euh Vigipirate très voilà du
contexte terroriste et quand il a voulu
faire passer dans le droit commun des
mesures de des mesures d'exception donc
c'est aussi un thème récurrent oui
évidemment et alors la question de
l'étatence c'était l'une des
interrogations des parlementaires ils
étaient quand même très remontés
notamment les sénateurs après avoir
entendu le le préfet NZ hier je propose
à Jonathan du du Priz de nous rejoindre
parce que euh cette audition de Laur NZ
était évidemment diffusée en direct sur
sur Public Sénat bonsoir jeonathend vous
l'avez suivi avec euh attention dans
quel état d'esprit est arrivé le le
préfet de police de Paris bah écoutez il
est venu euh s'expliquer hein se se
justifier devant les parlementaires
après ces annonces d'hier qui ont été
quand même ass c'est mal perçu ici au
Sénat alors vous allez le voir sur sur
cet écran donc il a dévoilé il est
revenu plus en détail sur ce qui a été
annoncé dans dans Le Parisien et
notamment sur ces fameuses zones
strictement réglementées où les les
piétons les vélos pourront circuler en
revanche voitures deux roues seront
interdits de ces périmètres sauf
dérogation et il y en a une multitude il
en a expliqué certaines notamment les
Riverin on s'ans doute c'est une
évidence les taxis les commerçants et
pourquoi pas aussi les agents EDF bon
voilà voye un peu l'idéeusine à gaz sur
maisuusine à gaz ceuxl devront en tout
cas s'enregistrer sur une fameuse
plateforme numérique en fournissant des
justificatifs de déplacement et ça va
générer un QR code à présenter lors de
ces fameux contrôles alors lor nounz
devant les sénateur il dit qu'au
contraire c'est un dispositif qui a déjà
existé déjà éprouvé et qui a été très
simple à mettre en œuvre notamment à
biarit
écoutez-le il y a eu le G7 à biarit en
2019 c'est ce qui a été fait c'est ce
qui a été fait il y avait une plateforme
d'enregistrement pour les riverins de
manière à pouvoir justifier de l'accès
au périmètre de mémoire d'ailleurs AB
biarit ça concernait aussi les piétons
je rappelle que je ne parle que de la
circulation routière automobile
automobile voilà il nous paraissait plus
simple de prévoir une plateforme avec
justificatif papier QR code comme j'ai
pu le dire dans Le Parisien moi j'en
sais rien on va en discuter dans la
concertation on verra ce que veulent les
gens en général les gens préfèrent quand
même les QR codes parce que ça permet au
contrôle de lâcher et les gens passent
on tout ça on en discutera voilà on en
discutera donc ça veut dire que tout ça
est encore à l'état de concertation les
dérogations les périmètres tout ça c'est
concertation avec les riverins les élus
les acteurs alors justement je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure beaucoup de
parlementaires qui étaient extrêmement
méfiant sur le le risque de dérive ouais
hier les parlementaires étaient très
remontés beaucoup étaient très inquiets
de possibles atteintes aux liberté
individuelles et de la difficulté
d'imbrication de ces différents
périmètres qui ne tombent pas tous sous
le coup des même des mêmes
réglementations par exemple il y en a
certains qui tombent sous le coup du de
la Loi antiterroriste de 2017 d'autres
non il y a aussi des sénateurs qui se
sont indigner hein que finalement le le
cadre initial de de ces restrictions
débordent et qui se rapproche petit à
petit de ce qu'on a connu pendant la la
période covid lors de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et Laurent nounz évidemment il
s'est justifié sur ce point très
clairement écoutez pour lui il n'y a
rien de comparable avec la période covid
j'ai entendu donc des comparaisons avec
l'état d'urgence il faut une loi et
cetera bon tout le monde se souvient que
l'état d'urgence c'était quand même des
contraintes qui étaient d'un autre
niveau d'un autre niveau on était sur
des mesures où vous deviez rester à
votre domicile avec des des contrainte
pénale pénale moi la contrainte qu'il y
a à mes périmètres de circulation c'est
que vous rentrez pas c'est c'est tout
vous garez votre voiture et vous rentrez
à pied donc avec des contraintes pénales
une série de mesures qui étaient
beaucoup plus restrictives il ne SAG il
ne SAG agissit pas de il ne s'agissait
pas évidemment de de de d'un simple une
simple
restriction le fait de pénétrer en
véhicule dans une zone voilà Thomas et
donc vous l'entendez le le préfet de
police de Paris s'est montré très
rassurant devant les sénateurs et
notamment sur le fondement enrooit de
ces fameuses restrictions ce que les
sénateurs semblaient pas forcément
savoir il a parlé d'un arrêté de 2011
publié par l'acneil permettant de
restreindre les conditions de
circulation dans le cadre d'un grand
événement ce qui a sembl en tout cas
plutôt convaincre l'assistance et à
noter aussi que les parlementaires il
comptent poser quelques questions à
Gérald armanin ce soir dans le cadre de
l'examen des crédits sécurité du budget
merci beaucoup
Jonathan je me retourne vers vous parce
qu'on a parlé de l'état d'urgence déjà
tout à l'heure donc cette différence la
faite entre par le préfet de police
entre le cadre grand événement et l'état
d'urgence on serait pas dans l'état
d'urgence vous entendez cet argument ou
vous vous en doutez un peu oui on
l'entend et on de toute façon je pense
pas que c'était vraiment la réelle
interrogation non plus des sénateurs
c'est pas d'avoir l'impression qu'on
bascule dans un nouvel état d'urgence
plus qu'un contrôle très fort sur les
libertés je pense que c'est vraiment ça
qui a attiré l'attention de nos
parlementaires et c'est c'est heureux
parce que au fond même si on est dans un
contexte grand événement et où à mon
avis le pouvoir exécutif est évidemment
fondé à à pouvoir être le seul à à agir
il faudrait pas non plus qu'on en arrive
à des restrictions qui vous l'avez dit
amènne à des usines à gaz c'est-à-dire
que la liberté et la règle la
restriction et l'exception je c'est pas
de moi c'est du Conseil d'État ça date
de 1906 donc la la la grande question
c'est ce dire est-ce qu'on va pas en
arriver à ce que on soit amené à se
justifier à exercer des libertés de
stationnement de circulation alors
certes ça peut se justifier par
l'événnement on on utilise biarit c'est
pas la même temporalité non plus là ça
sera sur des jours des semaines et voilà
il y a des droits qui sont ceux des
riverins qui doivent être procédés qui
doivent être protégés je veux dire dans
dans leur exercice donc c'est c'est
toutes ces questions qui à mon avis
méritaient vraiment cette audition et je
crois que le le le préfet a un petit peu
tort de de de minimiser le cadre certes
ce sont des restrictions de seule
circulation des véhicules ça va qu mmere
des données qui vont tre partagé ça va
être aussi des libertés individuelles
qui vont tre limité et sur ça il faut
faire qu même vraiment très attention au
cadre qui est utilisé je pense que le
Parlement aurait au moins sur une loi
cadre ou ne serait-ce que sur un débat
sans vote aurait pu être consulté et je
pense que c'est vraiment cette
interrogation là cette question là que
se posent les parlementaires aujourd'hui
alors sur la la cérémonie d'ouverture
maintenant Jean-Baptiste Guéan alors là
on est dans un niveau d'interdit encore
plus important je crois que même les
aéroports de Paris seront fermés pendant
pendant plusieurs heures c'est ça bah on
est dans un contexte où on va devoir
sécuriser quelque chose qui ne s'est
jamais fait c'est-à-dire sur plus de 6
km on va avoir la totalité des
délégations du monde et on va avoir la
concentration de risque la plus
importante de ces jeux et donc on va
dimensionner le dispositif en fonction
de ces risques là avec les impératifs
qui sont ceux de la sécurité mais aussi
du droit et donc on est confronté à un
dilemme jusqu'où on sécurise on a du mal
à gérer les foules on l'a vu avec la
finale de la Ligue des Champions euh la
Coupe du Monde rugby nous a rassuré mais
au début il y a eu quelques quak on
n'est pas à l'abri aussi de revis ce
qu'on a pu voir avec les émeutes et
cetera on est sur une situation extrême
ouais il y a eu un pré alors c'est
évidemment pas pas comparable mais quand
même la cérémonie d'ouverture de de
l'euro de foot 2016 on est on est on est
sur le Champ de Mars c'est ça on est on
n pas dans un stade complètement fermé
le périmètre et c'était
pas il y a d'autres dangers c'est-à-dire
que à l'époque on avait en peut-être le
risque terroriste là on a quand même la
guerre russie- Ukraine si les Russes
sont présents ou s'ils sont absents ça
va aussi entraîner des réactions on
n'est pas à l'abri d'un risque
terroriste j'ai envie de dire habituel
et puis après il y a la question de la
gestion des flux aujourd'hui on ne sait
plus gérer les flus on le voit avec les
supporters ouais chaque match
aujourd'hui est suivi d'une ind
direction de déplacement et aujourd'hui
ce qu'on voit autour des stades on parle
de liberté individuelle on empêche des
gens d'aller se déplacer pour aller voir
des matchs et quand on le fait pas bah
ça donne ce qui s'est passé à oui donc
ça pose de trois questions oui ça pose
évidemment plusieurs questions et alors
cette cérémonie d'ouverture elle pose
aussi beaucoup de questions euh au
bouini c'est l'un des symboles
intemporels de du Paris éternel on
pourrait dire comme ça il y a un risque
en tout cas c'est ce qu' leur est pour
l'instant demandé pour certains de
devoir fermer boutique écoutez comme on
a l'habitude de dire ce que les cru de
1910 que l'occupation ce que même
Napoléon I n'a pas réussi à faire les
Jeux Olympiques vont peut-être réussir à
le faire c'est-à-dire à nous faire
disparaître voilà c'est pas nous faire
disparaître pour toujours mais on sait
quand ils vont retirer les boîtes on
sait vraiment pas ils ont dit aussi vite
que possible il est métron ce qui veut
rien dire pratiquement Florence Bertou
je crois que vous assistiez ce jeudi à
une réunion avec le préfet sur cette
question des bouquinistes là surtout je
pense que ça a été filmé le soir où il y
a eu des RAM demande sur ma
proposition un test bon euhit comme test
démon les boes on enlève on enlève les
boîtes euh d'abord le le dispositif est
énorme hein il y avait plusieurs camions
il je sais pas combien de de de
personnes à la manutention si vous me
passez cette expression euh ces boîtes
sont toutes vieilles alors c'est vrai
qu'elles ont été un peu rafistolées bon
et euh si vous voulez la la la la
particularité à la fois la cruauté du
dispositif c'est que ce sont des
concessions donc des concessions euh sur
le domaine public
sans versement et on le comprend de
redevance parce que vous savez que un
bouiniste gagne entre 600 € et un petit
SMIC quand vraiment c'est c'est les les
les bons mois hein je veux dire faut
faut quand même voir ce que c'est donc
ce sont des métiers de de passion
d'ailleurs je connais le le bouiniste
qui a été qui a été interviewé et quand
il dit bah la scène sans les
bouquinistes c'est pas tout à fait la
scène oui mais l'argument c'est dire
attention risque terroriste si on on
peut pas assurer la sécurité avec avec
les Bou euh si j'ai bien compris parce
qu'il y a plusieurs séries d'arguments
en terme de sécurité qui nous ont été
euh qui ont été euh objectés euh il y a
euh le fait que euh il y a il y a des
risques de mouvement de foule et avoir
euh ces boîtes je rappelle qu'il y en a
900 il y en a pas 900 qui se
concerernent on est potentiellement
autour de 400 500 on n pas on sait pas
encore précisément combien de de boîtes
hein l'affaire dure quand même depuis
des mois hein on sait toujours pas si
c'est 400 boîtes 500 euh bon euh alors
moi je suis un peu donc il a risque de
mouvement de foule alors on dit il y a
un risque de mouvement de foule ce que
je comprends le préfet lui-même l'a dit
voilà regardons les images de sou ce qui
est vrai mais qu-ce qui s'était passé à
sou pardon et ben vous aviez eu des des
morts à cause de mouvement de foule
absolument terrible bon donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce que vous disiez le
mouvement de foule c'est c'est toujours
la chose absolument incroyable alors il
y a peut-être un risque de mouvement de
foule sur les boîtes il y en a aussi sur
les parapets sur les ponts sur toutes je
dirais les exro
de nos monuments bon ça c'est la
première chose mais je crois que
l'argument de fond aujourd'hui c'est que
on n pas assez de policiers assez
d'agents de sécurité pour tout protéger
donc vous savez qu'une des solutions
avait été de dire et bien on va les on
va faire le déminage mais là encore on
nous dit il va falloir tout déminer donc
déminer en plus ces boîtes c'est un
exercice qui paraît extraordinairement
compliqué on
aurait des moy hum voilà alors
maintenant le sujet c'est ça va mettre
combien de temps et et on va en enlever
et on en va en enlever combien mais
c'est un peu dommage qu'une cérémonie
populaire commence par enlever quand
même une des spécificités je crois qu'il
manque 25000 agents de sécurité par
rapport à à la situation et qu'on est
déjà à moins 20000 par rapport à la
situation qu'on devrait avoir donc
effectivement il y aura un énorme sujet
humain ouais ça ça rappelle un quoi que
Baptiste Guegan JO de Londres juste
avant le début des jeux il y a quoi il y
a un déficit de de de personnel de
sécurité c'est ça ça on le sait depuis
plusieurs années et le souci c'est que
depuis la fin du covid on a un énorme
problème de recrutement et de formation
et donc face à cette difficulté on
essaie de former mais on va pas les
sortir de nulle part et la grande
difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui bah on
est face à un impératif de sécurité on
doit respecter certains standards et se
protéger de risques qui sont quand même
accrus c'est pas la même situation com
de la candidature et en face vous avez
pas forcément les moy moyen humain c'est
même pas simplement une question
financière et donc à un moment donné il
y a cette équation que s'il faut
sacrifier les boîtes des bouinistes ou
les déplacer pendant 2 mois et à un
moment donné il y aura un choix
politique à faire il faudra qu'il soit
assumé par ceux qui le font mais il
faudra trancher Londres il ait fallu
faire venir des militaire en urgence
c'est ça alors ça c'est la grande
question est-ce qu'on militarise
l'événement est-ce que aujourd'hui si
vous disposez des militaires est-ce
qu'ils sont formés à ça il y a le risque
aussi de surmilitariser l'ensemble c'est
qu'à moment donné vous gâchez
l'expérience parce que l'idée c'est
quand même Paris avec ses images pas
forcément Paris avec le dispositif
Sentinel évidemment bon il y a tout ça
ce qu'on voit surtout c'est que on est
en train de se gâcher nous-même la fête
parce qu'on devrait être en train de
préparer justement cet événement là en
se disant on accueille le monde on va
montrer ce qui est capable de faire la
FR moi suis un peu moins pessimiste que
vous on est encore loin quand même du du
début des Jeux et cette passion et ce
côté plus festif ça ça viendra sûment
dans les derni bien peutre bah oui oui
évidemment einin le message sécuritaire
il est aussi destiné en dehors de la
France au touristes étrangers ou aux
États étrangers et cetera et cetera
c'est c'est un message important quoi
c'est un message important il faut pas
oublier on l'a dit vous vous avez eu
raison de le rappeler que la candidature
est ancienne finalement et alors bon les
engagements qui ont été pris devraient
pas forcément être changés ça c'est
c'est aussi une charte qui est qui est
donc importante à respecter
mais le message qu'on peut apporter à
l'étranger du tout sécuritaire alors
certes pour nos citoyens il est un peu
blessant puisque il nous rappelle ces
périodes de covid mais il est aussi
extrêmement rassurant c'est-à-dire que
on est dans un contexte international
avec une guerre on l'a dit dans l'Europe
avec une guerre au Moyen-Orient et puis
aussi euh dans notre population l'idée
d'être absolument dans la sécurité c'est
quelque chose qui renvoie à des signaux
d'un État fort et en ce moment dans
l'opinion hein on en a quand même
vraiment profondément besoin donc c'est
ce paradoxe il faut qu'on reste dans la
famille il faut qu'on reste dans les
valeurs du sport il faut qu'on soit dans
cette idée de la convivialité de la
France et et et du Paris Belle Époque
éternelle comme vous disiez Thomas euh
mais à la fois il faut aussi arriver à
respecter le droit les libertés et ça
c'est des impératifs qu'on a raison de
se poser suffisamment tôt je crois oui
évidemment euh Tam je me tourne vers
vous parce que les les annonces de du
préfet nunz hier ça a quand même euh
interpellé les parlementaires d'autant
plus que des textes de loi consacré aux
jeux olympiques il y en a eu plusieurs
il y en a eu quelques-uns oui hein
depuis 2017 date à laquelle on a appris
l'attribution des Jeux il y a eu et bien
des lois la loi du 27 mars 2018 la loi
du 2 août 2019 étaient là plutôt pour
simplifier les procédures hein pour
accélérer les travaux pour ce qui
s'apparente bien sûr à une course contre
la montre et puis il y a eu la dernière
loi en date celle de mai 2023 dont
l'objet principal était justement la
sécurité c'était de prévoir les
dispositifs en terme de sécurité elle a
instauré notamment la vidéosurveillance
avec intelligence artificielle les
fameuses caméras augmentées qui seront
expérimenté pour les jeux et même
jusqu'en 2025 la gauche à l'époque
c'était déjà inquiété de dérives
d'atteintes aux droits fondamentaux les
sénateurs avaient davantage encadrer le
dispositif d'où cette question mais
comment est-il possible que cette
histoire de QR code n''est pas été
débatue à ce momentlà qu'elle sort
seulement maintenant du chapeau alors
qu'il a eu donc un texte adopté il y a
moins d'un an alors justement
explication pourquoi bon ben la première
chose c'est ce qu' a dit Laurin nè tout
à l'heure il a dit il y a pas forcément
besoin d'une loi je me base sur un
arrêté de 2011 bon on peut aussi se dire
que on découvre chaque jour un peu plus
que la grande fête de l'olympisme est un
méga défi en terme de sécurité
d'organisation qu'on a pas forcément
tout prévu et qu'on invente he qu'on a à
force de marcher quoi quand vous
organisez une fête vous savez il y a
toujours un moment hein genre 1 heure
avant vous espérez que les invités ne
seront pas à l'heure et ben
là on est on est un peu à ce moment-là
c'est la montée de stress à tous les
étage la scène sera-t-elle prête pour
accueillir les épreuves de nage en eau
libre les transports en commun qui sont
une grande épreuve olympique du
quotidien pour les Franciliens est-ce
qu'ils vont permettre de circuler
correctement entre les sites olympiques
annidalgo a déjà répondu non et en plus
leur prix va doubler sur la période
alors qu'au départ on avait promis la
gratuité des transports pour les
détenteurs de billets et maintenant donc
pour couronner le tout cette histoire de
QR code et le Parlement comme laacil qui
découvre ça donc il dans Le Parisien
dans les médias ressuscitant et bien le
spectre de la pandémie du covid et voilà
donc où le bas blaesse d'un coup les
gios riment donc avec confinement
surtout pour les Parisiens surtout pour
les riverins de quoi mettre un peu plus
un coup à la promesse de grande fête
populaire des jeux olympiques mais alors
c'est c'est drôle parce que au même
moment on se réjouit d'obtenir les Jeux
Olympiques d'hivers de 2030 c'est pas
encore officiel mais on est les seuls
candidats tout à fait hasard du
calendrier devrait être bon
effectivement ça a l'air bon ça réjouit
toute la classe politique de Laurent
vquia Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron
qui dans un tweet a donc salué
l'organisation prochaine de ces jeux
dans les Alpes je cite donc ce tweet des
jeux innovants durables et inclusifs qui
vont faire rayonner la France et sa
montagne voilà la promesse est
importante bon innovant oui pourquoi pas
inclusif pour Paris on sait que c'est
déjà foutu hein pour les transports
durable c'était la promesse des gios de
Paris on verra bien pour les gios divers
c'est vraiment pas gagné he parce que la
Naig utilisée sur les derniers gios
était à 80 % artificiel lors des Jeux de
soi 90 % artificiel pour ceux de Pyong
Chang en Corée du Sud et la palme c'est
tout de même les gos de Pékin l'année
dernière neige à 100 % artificiel et
cette image qui a choqué beaucoup de
monde he cette rampe de lancement qu'on
a vu au au milieu de la friche
industrielle de chouang en plein climat
harideune rampe de lancement recouverte
donc de neige artificielle des jeux
innovant durable inclusif attention donc
aux grandes promesses elle crée beaucoup
d'attentes et non tenu beaucoup de
déception bon on devrait avoir un peu
plus de neige quand même que pour les
les godivers Asiatiques qui qui se
tiendront en Arabie Saoudite je vous le
rappelle c'est vrai mais en 2030 il y
aura-t-il beaucoup de neige dans les
Alpes ça c'est une vraie question mais
on va quand même se réjouir d'obtenir
les les les Jeux Olympiques euh Florence
Bertou sur le le le décalage entre le
projet initial on peut parler du coût
aussi de du budget global de C alors il
y a l'inflation qui est arrivée
évidemment depuis 2 ans est-ce que ça
explique tous les dépassements non euh
on Nura pas d'éléphant blanc quand même
hein faut pas voir faut quand même voir
ce qui est positif objectivement
regardez ce qui se passe autour
de du méia Center ce qui se passe autour
du village olympique moi je suis allé
sur site d'ailleurs avec le préfet de de
de de de régions ça c'est plutôt positif
et et et surtout les délais sont tenus
bon donc c'est bien il y a peu de pays
qui ont réussi à faire ça maintenant je
je pense que le coût de la sécurité va
être beaucoup plus important que ce
qu'on avait imaginé on avait imaginé à
peu près 500 millions d'euros je pense
que
euh on sera objectivement bien au-dessus
notamment pour les raisons que vous que
vous avez euh que vous avez mentionné
donc oui le coup important le le coût de
la le coût de la cérémonie d'ouverture
j'y reviens un peu je pense qu'il va
être quand même très élevé voilà alors
vous parle moi je trouve ça génial he je
trouve que c'est vraiment le panache à
la française dans dans
tout aprs bon courage pour l'organiser
je suis d'accord avec vous c'est c'est
quand même alors la réalité c'est que
c'est quand même sur 10 km hein vous
avez dit tout à l'heure parce que il y a
quand même 3 km où il va falloir stocker
tout toutes les délégations enfin
stocker pardonnez-moi de ce mot
malheureux mais enfin ça prendra un peu
de temps pour que toutes non mais Don
donc je dis ça pourquoi parce que ça
veut dire aussi le défi en terme de
sécurité c'est ça c'est c'est c'est
évidemment le le long du parcours il il
va démarrer 10 km avant donc c'est le
panache à la française mais euh bon il
faut pas euh avoir comme on dit chez moi
les yeux plus gros que le ventre parfois
je je j'en termine juste sur un point
c'est que euh peut-être peut-être j'ose
le dire qu'il faudrait un peu réduire
aussi la voilure sur les accès au KO
d'ailleurs Monsieur le Préfet de police
a déjà euh réduit alors faut peut-être
rappeler avec billet c'est euh k bas et
et et accès gratuit qu ha c'est c'est
gratuit d'ailleurs en bas c'est le cojot
hein euh en haut c'est pas le cojot et
euh monsieur pr pardonnez-moi et et et
le et le monsieur le Préfet de police a
déjà euh indiqué que on allait réduire
l'accès de
350000 euh personnes vous vous souvenez
après justement le 7 octobre il a il a
fait cette annonce là bon donc peut-être
que une une une des pistes sera
aussi notamment pour limiter les risques
effets de de foule et cetera de de
limiter un peu la voilure sur les accès
au KO mais sur la question des coûts moi
je voudrais revenir quand même sur
quelque chose le coût moyen des jeux
c'est 10 milliards aujourd'hui on était
sur une candidature à 6 qui va aller sur
7 on va être les jeux finalement les
plus économiques par rapport aux 25
dernières années on est déjà
h pour l'instant on y est pas bon et si
on est en dessous de 10
on on sera meilleurs sur les 50
dernières années on est sur une
augmentation de 130 % par rapport au
budget initial on n pas doublé ce budget
c'estàd que on a tenu les coûts
là-dessus la France initie un nouveau
modèle olympique ok il aurait pu être
plus économique c'est évident mais il y
avait pas la même quantité de risque au
moment où on est arrivé sur la
candidature et C et là-dessus on a
vraiment été capable de maintenir ces
coupsl c'est ça ça ça nou mod c'est quoi
pardon interrompre le nouveau modèle
c'est de construire moins de nouveaux
stades c'est'appu surrrur des sites qui
étaient déjà présents on a dimensionné
l'événement pour que tout ce qui soit
fait soit durable et qu'on est justement
pas d'éléphant blanc on aura pas de
sites qui vont être abandonnés éléphant
blanc c'est un stade qui reste qui est
inutilisé qui transformme par exemp
Brésil en prison ou le pire exemp par
exle vous avez des éléphants blancs ou
la Coupe du monde de football en donc il
y a pas d'éléfant blanc et ça c'est
c'est vraiment un modèle et c'est tout à
fait
vraiose il y a la question du du méga
événement aujourd'hui sportif c'est
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est encore dans
dans des démocraties en capacité de
mettre 6 7 8 milliards d'euros sur des
événements qui durent moins d'un mois
ouais allez on va on va écouter parce
qu'il y a la grande question évidemment
vous parliez du stress de de de celui
qui organise une fête est-ce qu'ils vont
venir et puis deux est-ce qu'il pourrai
pas arriver en retard les deux les deux
sentiments contradictoires bref est-ce
qu'on sera prèt le 26 juillet écoutez
Clément B le ministre des Transports qui
se veut évidemment
rassurant oui nous serons prêts à tenir
et nous tiendrons les engagements que
nous avons pris et les engagements de
transport que nous avons pris c'est
d'abord la ligne de vie des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques la ligne 14
prolongé au nord jusqu'à Saint-Denis au
sud jusqu'à l'aéroport d'Orly ce sont
des travaux et je le dis pour remercier
les équipes les milliers d'agents qui
sont engagés à Île-de-France mobilité à
la RATP chez Alstom ce sont des gens qui
travaillent aujourd'hui jour nuit et
weekend qui sont totalement mobilisés
pour réussir un défi incroyable qui est
d'avoir les premiers jeux qui seront à
100 % accessibles pour tous les sites et
tous les spectateurs en transport public
ça ne s'est jamais fait ni à Londres ni
ailleurs évidemment Clément bon répond à
la mre de Paris à nidalgo qui avait
déclaré à propos de de des transports
qu'on ne sera pas prêt euh les jeux
doivent faire l'objet d'un consensus
politique à Charl bizin suis totalement
angélique quand je quand je dis
ça alors je je suis pas spécialiste du
du sport du tout mais un petit peu plus
de de du jeu politique et j'ai un peu le
sentiment quand même que le sport reste
encore dans euh l'imaginaire populaire
et au moins dans la classe politique
comme quelque chose qui appelle un temps
mort euh en terme de joute politique
politicienne et cetera néanmoins je
pense que jusqu'au mois d'organisation
on entendra quand même encore parler de
ces jeux la preuve aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a évidemment des
forts enjeux démocratiques techniques
d'accessibilité l'opposition aurait tort
de ne pas s'en saisir mais je crois en
effet que cette idée d'avoir des
candidatures communes on l'a dit pour
les godivers aussi tout ça est censé un
petit peu ranimer fr il jamaisiant
franis les compés spes donc je P que
c'est ai une manière de raviver l'esprit
national cette idée de patrimoine voilà
je pense vraiment que la classe
politique est assez unanime autour de
cette question il y a pas tant
d'événement où on fait
nation et donc la sortie d'algo votre
avis làdessus c'est un écran de
fumée parmi d'autres
après
on on pas par desetombécomi parce que
l'idée quand même c'est aussi c'est pas
un gros mot d'attendre des retombées
économiques qui seront au moins
équivalentes à court et moyen terme à ce
que ces Joos auront coûtter et pour le
moment on est plutôt autour de de
retomber enfin le chiffre qui circule
c'est toujours 10 milliards d'euros on
est plus à 13 voilà mais attendez pardon
des des jeux qui rapportent de l'argent
ça ça c'est quasiment jamais arrivé non
en terme de communication vous allez
avoir une visibilité de Paris ça déjà
été le cas depis qu'on a les jeux et
vous allez pouvoir travailler l'image de
marque de la ville ce qu'on appppelle du
City branding vous allez travailler
aussi l'image de la marque France et
donc vous allez pouvoir promouvoir vos
industries de sécurité c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aussi qu'on est pas trop de
problème votre capacité touristique et
finalement tout ce que vous offrez au
monde le
BTP vous vous pensez que ces jeux seront
rentable n finirons par rapporter de
l'argent à la France je dis que il va y
avoir des retombées
ça est très documenté aujourd'hui enfin
c'est pas totalement extravagant euh on
imagine aussi créer enfin c'est pas on
imagine on a il y aurait 2500000 emplois
à peu près créés la question de savoir
évidemment si derrière ces emplois vont
être pérénisés donc oui les jeux les
jeux apportent aussi des retombées vous
avez des des milliers de touristes qui
vont arriver enfin des millions bah il
va falloir les loger ils vont aller dans
des hôtels ils vont aller un peu aussi
Airbnb bon c'est pas forcément ce qui
est de mieux mais je tout ça ça va faire
vivre aussi not notre commce et donc le
sujet important aussi en matière de de
sécurité va être dans les périmètres
quelles vont être on l'a pas évoqué mais
les commerces qui vont pouvoir ouvrir
parce que quand vous avez une brasserie
dans le périmètre de
sécurité quand même une de de vos
préoccupations c'est de savoir si vous
allez pouvoir ouvrir si vous allez avoir
un cadre aussi d'horaire pour ouvrir si
vos salariés les livraisons vont pou se
faire dans des conditions correctes et
cetera et cetera donc c'est pas un petit
un petit sujet que ce volet là qui a pas
encore été évoqué par les parlementaires
alors la France a évidemment déjà
organisé beaucoup de grands événements
sportifs on peut dire que globalement ça
s'est bien passé dernier ate c'était la
Coupe du monde de rugby ce que n'a pas
manqué de rappeler Gérald haranin
notamment en rendant hommage aux forces
de l'ordre il est évident que les moyens
exceptionnels que nous avons eu par la
commom de rugby seront encore décuplés
la France a montré qu'elle était capable
d'organiser dans un contexte d'attentat
de difficultés extérieure extrêmement
forte la venue du roi Charles pendant
plusieurs jours en même temps la venue
du sa Sainté le pape à Marseille pendant
2 jours et en même temps la cou de rugby
et en même temps des manifestations et
en même temps garantir la sécurité des
Français donc c'est la première fois que
la France savait faire autant de choses
à la fois dans je crois des conditions
optimales il est évident que pour les
Jeux Olympique cette préparation nous
permettra de répondre à toutes les
questions qui se
poseront est-on faire peur
aussi moi je crois que de toute façon
l'anticipation est quand même la clé
d'une politique publique réussi donc la
question que je me pose moi plutôt c'est
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment anticipé
parce que aujourd'hui on joue à se faire
peur parce que on est proche de
l'échéance mais finalement ces choses-là
on on l'a dit avec lesdit auable sont
des choses qu'on sait depuis 2017 donc
le cadre législatif la manière dont on
va évoluer la manière dont on va
organiser les commerces les transports
et cetera c'est quand même des choses
qui auraient pu faire l'objet d'un plan
sur lequel on aurait pu réussir bien en
AM mon à mon avis à être plus clair on
devrait déjà avoir ses réponses là euh
moi je je crois en effet que
l'anticipation c'est quelque chose qui
nous manque aujourd'hui et et je pense
que ça fait partie un peu du phénomène
d'emballement et du phénomène exécutif
c'està-dire que on se rend compte de
toute façon dans toutes les questions
d'urgence qu'elles soit sanitaire ou
sportive ou autre que dès lors qu'on
panique et qu'on a besoin d'aller vite
on va avoir besoin d'une législation
exécutive mais c'est précisément ça
qu'il faudrait essayer d'éviter qu'on
ait le temps de discuter de préparer les
gens les riverins l'économie et ça c'est
peut-être quelque chose sur lequel pour
moi on a commencé à faillir ouais
Jean-Baptiste Guan il y a une petite
musique autour de l'incapacité supposée
de la France d'organiser ses Jeux
Olympiques sauf que si on regarde un peu
derrière il y a quand même aussi une
campagne de désinformation complètement
c'est ce qu'on voit aussi c'est l'enjeu
qui consiste à déstabiliser le pays pour
ses positions politique et diplomatique
et là aujourd'hui on voit l'axe
souvenez-vous des punaises de lit
souvenez-vous de tout ce qui arrive dans
nos rues on est dans des logiques qui
qui peuvent affecter littéralement
l'image du pays sa crédibilité
internationale c'est pour ça aussi qu'il
faut pas qu'on en rajoute et qu'on
rentre pas non plus dans dans dans ces
débats qui sont logiques légitimes et
normaux dans une démocratie mais si on
compare par rapport à d'autres
événements je pense à la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar pour y être allé pour avoir vu
ce qui se passait 3 mois avant le niveau
de désorganisation était quand même
assez sidérant euh les grands événements
sportifs sont jamais prêts 3 mois à
l'avance avec tout qui est calé on est
sur ce qu'on appelle des structures
apprenantes euh c'est-à-dire qu'on est
capable de réagir vite mais c'est jamais
préparé à ce point-là à ce niveau de
détail là avec ce niveau de stress là h
euh Florence Bertou le fait que le le
comité d'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques vienne de on l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure de donner à la France
l'organisation des des des jeux divers
de 2030 c'est quand même un très bon
signe c'estàdire que si le cojot depuis
des mois nous nous voyez empétré dans
l'organisation de ces ces jeux 2024 je
pense pas qu'il nous aurait bien s d'AC
avec ce que vous dites enfin se poser
des questions qui sont des questions
légitimes en démocratie euh ça veut pas
dire mettre mettre en doute la capacité
d'organisation de la la France on a
quand même euh quoi qu'on en dise des
des des services de sécurité qui sont
très très opérationnels ce que disait le
ministre de l'intérieur est très vrai
quand même hein franchement euh
organiser les événements en même temps
hein le le pape le roi Charles et cetera
tout ça c'était quand même très très
très très compliqué avec c'est vrai
aussi des manifestations donc euh il
faut pas non plus euh comment dirais-je
verser dans un dans une autre forme
d'angélisme qui est de ne pas euh
imaginez que ça arrange voilà certaines
puissances aussi voilà donc et comme
vous disiez très justement les grandes
manifestations sportifes mais pas que
hein quelques parfois quelques jours
avant il y a forcément oui des
ajustements qui qui qui doivent être
faits le CO c'est enfin a littéralement
féliciter la France pour son niveau
d'avancement c'était pas le cas des des
autres manif franchement je suis allé
sur le site du village olympique j' allé
vraiment sans sans arrièrepensée ni
positive ni négative j'ai quand même été
assez impressionné assez impressionné
par le le
professionnalisme des des entreprises
qui avaient achevé quand même une grande
partie et qui tenait le cap qui tenit le
cap ce qui est très très rare he la
solidéo est absolument extraordinaire
Solido c'est l'organisme qui s'occupe de
la
construction avec le problème justement
de l'approvisionnement en et du covid
c'est qu'ils ont une sacrée gagure
incroyable je voudrais il nous reste une
minute vous poser une dernière question
à Charlen sur les les procédures
judiciaire poss possible parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé du QR code le thème
central de notre débat c'était atteint
aux liberté on peut s'attendre à des
procédures judiciaires notamment sur
cette ce point précis de de de QR code
on a dit qu'on était heureux d'être en
démocratie et de pouvoir justement
l'apprécier bien sûr tout ce qui est
tout ce qui relève de l'autorité
administrative relèvera du juge
administratif et on peut estimer que le
risque contentieux est quand même très
fort alors si ça passe par une loi on
aura évidemment une saisine du Conseil
constitutionnel mais je pense pas qu'on
passera par une loi tous ces actes
administratifs là font l'obet d'une
sisine du Conseil d'État et ça arrivera
de toute façon même quelques jours avant
les Jeux on aura les fameux référés
qu'on a eu encore pour les
manifestations sportives footballistiqu
et qui parfois ont donné des surprises
parce que on a encore heureux des juges
administratifs très préoccupés par la
proportionnalité des libertés publiques
et qui ont parfois amené à tout devoir
désorganiser en 2 heures donc il faut
aussi tenir compte du fait que la
justice est très effic dans notre pays
et qu'elle sera peut-être quelque chose
à à rentrer dans les rouages bon la
moralité c'est qu'on a peut-être pas
envie d'être à la place du préfet NZ
parce que c'est quand même très très
compliqué à organiser c'est pas le seul
à s'en charger évidemment merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat
JeanBaptiste Guégan je rappelle le titre
de votre livre l'Atlas géopolitique du
sport qui est publié aux éditions
Autrement